THE POOL HAS BEEN USHERED INTO
THE CABINET ROOM.
ONCE WE GET THAT VIDEOTAPE, YOU
WILL SEE IT HERE LIVE ON FOX.
RUSSIA AND SYRIA SAY THAT TO
ISRAELI FIGHTER JETS CARRIED OUT
A DEADLY AIR STRIKE ON A SYRIAN
BASE.
SO FAR, ISRAEL IS NOT SAYING
ANYTHING.
CORRESPONDENT CONOR POWELL HAS
THE LATEST FROM JERUSALEM.
>> IT'S AN AIR STRIKE NO
GOVERNMENT HAS CLAIMED
RESPONSIBLY FOUR.
MOSCOW WAS POINTING THE FINGER
SQUARELY IN ISRAEL FOR THE
EARLY-MORNING BOMBING OF A
SYRIAN AIR BASE.
IT KILLED AT LEAST 14 PEOPLE
INCLUDING IRANIAN SOLDIERS.
>> Translator: THE AIR STRIKE
MUST BE INVESTIGATED.
OF COURSE THIS IS A VERY
DANGEROUS DEVELOPMENT.
>> OFFICIALLY ISRAEL IS NOT